Mila vielleicht die erste Frage an Sie
sie leben mittlerweile in Berlin ich
habe das auch gerade beschrieben jeder
vierte
moldawiainnen lebt mittlerweile im
Ausland also eine ein unglaublicher
Exodus vor allen Dingen an jungen Leuten
wie gespalten und in welchem Zustand ist
eigentlich ihr Heimatland ist Moldawien
wie würden sie das beschreiben
existiert erst seit 91 ist relativ
junges Land das muss man auch verstehen
und die schwierigste Zeit bis jetzt war
eigentlich die ersten zehn Jahren nach
dem nach dem Buch von Sowjetunion also
das war die Zeit wenn ja kein Strom gab
das wissen wir schon seit dieser Zeit
ich war damals ein Kind aber ich hätte
mich sehr gut wie man Hausaufgaben macht
und es gibt nur so Kerzen die dir dabei
helfen es war eine Zeit wenn es alle
alle Fabriken geschlossen waren
natürlich wurden die Leute gezwungen
ihren Existenz irgendwie zu verdienen
und sehr viele sind nach Ausland
gegangen das hat schon damals angefangen
seit
2005 ich glaube das waren schon nicht
nur
noch nicht nur erwachsene Leute sondern
Leute die von Mobilitätsprogramme
profitieren wollten und die wollten
Studieren im Ausland die wollten
erasmus-programme machen und so weiter
und so fort
ich glaube es ist auch wichtig zu sagen
dass momentan es gibt auch eine Tendenz
von nicht nur brain drain sondern auch
von Brain circulation also ich war
zuerst in Berlin in 2012 und 2013 danach
bin ich zurück nach Hause gegangen und
zehn Jahre dort weiter gearbeitet für
Moldau danach wegen persönlichen Gründen
bin ich wieder 21 nach Deutschland
gekommen aber ich kenne sehr viele Leute
unser Außenminister ist zurück aus
Frankreich gekommen und arbeitet jetzt
Regierung deswegen ja Chefin hat
gearbeitet als Ökonomie genau
Chefin hat gearbeitet in London ich
glaube aber meine Sando die Präsidentin
hat
in Amerika gearbeitet also deswegen ja
wir sind sehr sehr sehr betroffen von
dieser Migration aber manchmal vergisst
man auch über guter gute Beispiele und
sie sind nicht so viele aber man muss
darüber auch sprechen dass diese brain
circulation da ist und man muss das
fördern auch darüber reden wir gleich
die Frage auch wie wir darauf reagieren
sollten was ich so interessant war fand
Herr schmatzki vielleicht die Frage an
Sie ich meine wir alle haben über Moldau
und nie wirklich viel geredet auch nicht
in Sendungen wie dieser hier plötzlich
seit diesem Angriffskrieg reden wir über
Moldau und das was sie gerade
beschrieben haben gerade der letzte
Winter war unglaublich hart äh
stundenlange Stromausfälle auch das
Kabinett hat glaube ich getagt teilweise
in Dunkelheit und ohne Strom es muss man
sich mal vorstellen was das mit einem
Land macht und da wird sich im harten
moldawischen Winter keine Wärme kein
Strom keine Energie mehr hast sie sagen
dieses kleine Land über das wir jetzt
plötzlich das erste Mal uns wirklich
Gedanken machen ist ein gefunden es
fressen für diese russischen Kriegs
Gelüste warum weil
da nicht so gut geschützt ist wie andere
möglichen Ziele Russlands und ich denke
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass wenn
Russland in der Ukraine nicht gestoppt
wird wer das weitergehen wollen
dass das so nah dran
kein NATO Mitglied
und das Russland weitergehen wird in dem
Fall da bin ich mir auch sicher da sind
sie sich ganz sicher sie das ist
interessant ich habe ihre Texte gelesen
und einige davon wirklich tolle Texte wo
sie genau das beschreiben und sagen es
ist so unglaublich naiv zu glauben wenn
wir über Frieden reden wenn wir den
sagen wir machen euch ein Angebot ihr
kriegt ein Stückchen davon ein bisschen
was aus der Ukraine und dann hören die
auf damit das ist unvorstellbar naiv
sondern es ist im Gegenteil für die
Russen die Aufforderung erst recht
weiter zu machen warum
ich glaube sie stellen diese Frage weil
Russland in Deutschland Jahrzehnte lang
ein zu gutes Image hatte dieses Bild von
Russland russische Seele
Geistigkeit Kultur die Kultur war da hat
dieselbe war auch da aber hinter dieser
Oberfläche war das eine was wirklich
zählen die Gewalt und das wurde hier
nicht wahrgenommen deswegen wundert uns
das jetzt genau was passiert jetzt mit
diesem Russland woher diese Brutalität
diese Folter diese Videos wie einem beim
lebendigen bleiben der Kopf
abgeschnitten wird für Menschen
kastriert werden das und der Mutter ist
in der russischen Gesellschaft
drehen sich und dreht sich weiter
deswegen ist moldo Aachen Gefahr ich
hatte auch das Gefühl Herr Roth in
Moldau sind sich die Leute dieser Gefahr
sehr bewusst
und auch dieser wir haben das gerade auf
der Karte gesehen dieser kleine
Landstrich da dieser an eingefrorener
Konflikt sagen wir dann immer in
Wahrheit an unhaltbarer Zustand kann es
nicht drehen dieses seltsame Land das
sozusagen ein eigener Staat sein will
aber nur von Russland überhaupt
anerkannt wird an der eigene Währung hat
so so so plastikgeschoss teilweise das
ist völlig verrückt wenn man dort ist in
triaspol in der Hauptstadt
die Moldauer sind sich darüber im Klaren
wie groß diese Gefahr ist aber wir haben
das einfach
ignoriert für viel zu lange Zeit warum
für viel zu lange Zeit war das östliche
Europa für Terra Inkognita es war die
Einflusssphäre von Herrn Putin in die
wir uns gefälligst nicht einzumischen
haben das hören wir ja noch bis in die
heutige Zeit wann machen aus ihrer
Partei nicht nur ich glaube dass meine
Partei ein Spiegelbild der deutschen
Gesellschaft war wir haben uns wenn es
um den Osten Europas ging stark auf
Russland konzentriert wollten Russland
nicht
provozieren wir wollten Russland
nicht zu neuer Gewalt bringen und wir
haben damit die Souveränität dieser
jungen Länder wie das Mila sagte
eigentlich in Zweifel gezogen also ihr
könnt machen was ihr wollt aber wenn ihr
euch in Richtung Europa orientiert wenn
ihr unseren sicherheitsbündnissen
angehören wollt dann müssen wir euch
leider nein sagen und das ist jetzt
vorbei und das ist der einzige Trost
jemand angesichts dieses furchtbaren
Kriegs gegen die Ukraine haben kann wir
schauen jetzt aufmerksamer hin und ich
habe in meiner Zeit als ich im östlichen
Europa war eines gelernt wenn ich als
frustrierter Europäer meine Batterien
aufladen möchte dann gehe ich in die
Ukraine dann gehe ich nach Moldau oder
georgen rede mit den jungen Leuten die
haben noch Feuer die haben noch
Sehnsucht absolut die wollen einfach so
leben wie wir in Freiheit in Demokratie
in Wohlstand die wollen einfach ihren
europäischen Weiherhof live haben und
das darf nicht was exklusives sein nur
für den Norden für den West oder den
Süden Europas und dahin gehen ist es
jetzt was wir erleben eigentlich die
Wiedervereinigung Europas der Osten
Europa ist einfach momentan im Blick und
wir dürfen diesen Blick auch nicht
wieder verlieren er Meister sie sind
viel auch dort unterwegs sie kennen die
Verhältnisse dort waren auch in
transistrieren unter anderem aber wann
waren Sie zuletzt ja 2019 kurz vor 19
okay
um das einmal ganz kurz zu klären da
sehen wir es noch mal ein Bild
wie viele russische Soldaten sind dort
stationiert und was ist überhaupt der
Grund dafür warum gibt es diesen
seltsamen Streifen der sich ein eigenes
Land nennt es ist ein sehr kleiner
Streifen der hier östlich des Neste
verläuft und sich 19 der Fluss genau der
der
weitestgehend über dieses über diese
Linie hinweg das transnistrieren von der
Republik Molda also verbleibenden
ist ein Konflikt der ja auf die
Auflösung der Sowjetunion zurückgeht auf
die späten 80er Jahre die frühen 1990er
Jahre als ich transnistin abgespalten
hatte zu diesem Zeitpunkt damals war in
Moldau ist eine starke rumänische
Nationalbewegung an die Macht gekommen
und östlich des meiste transministerien
waren sie eben stärkere ukrainische
russische Bevölkerungsgruppen die sich
dort im sowjetischen
herrschaftsmodell den widersetzt haben
also Silber damals eigentlich die
Sowjetunion zu erhalten und und sich
diesen rumänischen
nationsbildungsprozess zu widersetzen es
kann dann zu einem kurzen Krieg 1992 und
dieser Krieg wurde dann beendet durch
das Eingreifen der 14 russischen Armee
und der General levet und danach hat
Russland diesen Konflikt eingefroren und
ja wenn wir jetzt auf auf
bin heute blicken auf dieser
kontrolliert oder ist das übertrieben
das zu sagen wie viele russische
Soldaten sind dort heute stationiert
ungefähr
1500 Soldaten aber es muss auch klar
sein dass die aus Russland kommen sind
nur so die
Führungsebene sozusagen aber die anderen
sind aus transistrieren die einfach auch
russische Pässe haben also und die Zahl
alle sagen 1500 ist immer relativ also
wenn man das jetzt mal sieht ne wo
dieses transistrieren liegt also direkt
angrenzend an die Ukraine wenn man dort
mit Leuten spricht die sagen die wir
hören wie die russischen Raketen dort
einschlagen das haben die alle
mitgekriegt warum so viele Menschen auch
speziellen dagegen die sitzen
aufgepacken Koffern bis heute die Leben
in Angst das heißt das wäre ein
mögliches Einfalls doof für Russland
dieser schmale Landstreifen wie würden
sie das beschreiben
in militärischer Perspektive ist ist das
fraglich also das auch was was Meier
Sando in einem übrigen in einem
ZDF-Interview gesagt hat die Ukraine
schützt aus militärischer Perspektive
die Republik Molda zur jetzigen
Zeitpunkt den den es hier zuzustimmen
ich sehe hier ein anderes Einfallstor
für Russland das Einfallstor kommt von
innen heraus es steht im Zeichen
hybrider Konflikt und Kriegsführung und
das Einfallstore geht darin den Staat
von innen heraus zu zersetzen die
Gesellschaft zu zersetzen die Politik zu
destabilisieren und alle Abhängigkeiten
die in
Moldau zu Russland aus historischen
Gründen bestehen es ist ein
posteriotischer Staat die zu bedienen
und dass das sind drei haupteinfalls
Punkte die die Moskau hier spielen kann
es ist zum einen die gespaltene
Gesellschaft das darf man nicht darüber
hinwegsehen dass ein Teil der
Gesellschaft tatsächlich nach Russland
liegt es ist nicht so dass sie alle in
den Westen blicken es sind politische
Kräfte die von Russland finanziert
werden und und hier im Sinne Moskau
seine Agitation eine russische betreiben
eine Antriebe anti-westliche und des
drittens der transministerin Konflikte
als Pfand gehalten wird also hier wird
das ist der Schlüssel der ein Moskau
liegt und dieser Konflikt wird bedient
wird das Land destabilisiert werden soll
wenn die Regierung destabilisiert werden
soll kann man diesen Konflikt immer
eskalieren und das war im Übrigen schon
seit den 1990er Jahren der Fall die
Politik Moskau sind der Hinsicht ist
radikaler geworden in den letzten Jahren
allerdings diese Haltung sobald ein Land
ausbrechen möchte aus dem News aus der
Perspektive Russlands aus dem Umgebung
wie man dort sagen würde wahrscheinlich
genauso Ausland sagt man dann Russland
sozusagen
ja 91 gesagt okay die Post sowjetischen
Länder sind Ausland wir kennen das Sinn
an aber sie sind nahes Ausland das heißt
sie gehören geopolitisch und ökonomisch
zu unserer Einflusszone und immer wenn
ein Land auszubrechen drohte hat man
einen konflik geschaffen bedient
instrumentalisiert um eine Annäherung an
den Westen zu unterbinden so und warum
mila ist die Bevölkerung so zerrissen
ich habe das auch so wahrgenommen dass
das im Grunde also ich weiß nicht wie
das Verhältnis ist aber mein Gefühl war
fast 50 50 mittlerweile ich glaube es
war mal anders so ich glaube wir als EU
waren schon mal attraktiver aber da gibt
es viele Enttäuschung Leute fühlen sich
zum Teil auch von uns wirklich im Stich
gelassen und gerade auch Deutschland
kommt eine besondere Rolle zu also bei
uns schaut man immer und die Leute haben
das Gefühl ihr seid so teilnahmslos
interessiert euch gar nicht so richtig
warum es bei uns geht aber warum ist die
andere Hälfte so pro russisch so
großartig waren die die guten alten
Zeiten ja dann auch nicht nein sie waren
nicht großartig ich glaube der Grund ist
dieser wechselhafte Geschichte weil
Moldau im 19 Jahrhundert war Teil des
russischen zahlreich ja danach war sie
Teil Rumäniens dann weil es Teil der
Sowjetunion und man muss sich vorstellen
auf diesem kleinen Territorium wohnen
momentan zweieinhalb Millionen Menschen
die eigentlich alle möglichen
Nationalitäten haben von Bulgarien
gagausen Russen Ukraine Molda oder
Männer und so weiter und natürlich es
ist sehr kompliziert dass so ein Multi
kulturelles Land
existiert und ja und in eine gleiche
Richtung gut deswegen es ist unglaublich
kompliziert und diese Polarisierung sie
ist seit
mehreren Jahren dabei und jetzt wird sie
einfach nur tiefe und Tiefe gespült und
gefüllt und ja
rot ich habe immer wieder auf dieser
Reise dieses Futter habe ich an einem
Sonntag in kishenau gemacht
da gibt es diese Proteste und diese
Proteste spielt dabei eine besondere
Rolle weil
mittlerweile auch belegt ist durch ein
paar sehr talentierte Kollegen
Kolleginnen Journalisten in China die
nachweisen konnten zweifelsfrei das ein
Teil dieser Leute die da demonstrieren
die gehen auf die Straße weil sie dafür
bezahlt werden von den Russen
offensichtlich dafür bezahlt werden
und was ich immer wieder hörte war der
Krieg in der Ukraine ist schlimm aber
noch schlimmer ist in Wahrheit die
russische Propaganda der gesagt
Jahrzehnten mittlerweile ausgesetzt sind
und mein Gefühl ist das funktioniert
auch man bringt die Leute dermaßen
durcheinander man macht die wuschig wie
man bei mir zu Hause sagen würde so dass
die Leute immer nicht mehr wissen wo
links und rechts und oben und unten ist
und jede Lüge kriegt irgendwann den
Charakter von Wahrheit und das ist
wahnsinnig gefährlich weil diese
Erzählung auch entsteht da gibt es diese
pro-europäische Präsidentin Frau Sandow
zum Beispiel dann versprechen die
Deutschen wieder ein paar Millionen
Hilfsgelder wo sind die eigentlich ah
die sind bestimmt von korrupten
Politikern geklaut worden und so weiter
das heißt sind wir wirklich ernsthaft in
der Lage dem zu begegnen
da müssen wir ja gar nicht bis nach
Moldau gehen die russische Lügen
Propaganda hat ja auch in Deutschland
sehr erfolgreich gewirkt also jeder der
auf den sozialen Medien unterwegs ist
wird sich irgendwann mit Russland treuen
Trollen auseinanderzusetzen haben die
einem sagen eigentlich ist
mitverantwortlich für den Krieg ähm die
USA eigentlich haben wir die
Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands
ignoriert eigentlich ist die NATO in der
Mitverantwortung also es sind solche
Märchen erzählt worden die es die die
die die die Trennung zwischen
Tätern und Opfern immer mehr in einen
Graubereich führen und am Ende gibt es
Menschen die Folgen einfach auch diesen
sehr einfachen und eingängigen Parolen
und das ist natürlich auch in
Transnistrien oder auch in Moldau der
Fall und wir haben diesen Staaten ja
auch über eine viel zu lange Zeit die
kalte Schulter gezeigt ich meine es war
in der Europäischen Union ein absolutes
No-Go
eine EU-Perspektive also eine Chance der
eu-beitzutreten hatten diese Länder
nicht bis zum 24 Juni vergangenen Jahres
Moldau und die Ukraine haben jetzt als
erste osteuropäische Staaten eine solche
Chance das ist eigentlich eine
Zeitenwende für Europa und damit
eröffnet sich die Chance diese Staaten
und diese Länder und diese
gesellschaftschaften
zusammenzubringen aber wir müssen jetzt
eben auch liefern und wenn Menschen
nicht wissen wie sie ihre Stromrechnung
bezahlen können wenn Menschen nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Miete zu bezahlen
haben wenn Menschen nicht wissen was aus
ihren Kindern wird dann ist man
natürlich auch anfällig für derartige
Parolen und da gibt es eben mindestens
einen Origin der inzwischen in Israel
lebt Herrscher der über seine mittels
Männer und Frauen Demonstranten bezahlt
und die treten dann auf und das ist mir
auch durch Freunde die in molder Leben
und auch in transnissen Leben immer
wieder geschädigt worden die werden dann
mit den Bussen dahin gekart und die
sorgen dann für Bambule das ist schlimm
aber ich will diese Menschen auch nicht
verteidigen ich will nur deutlich machen
auch wir haben ja lange in dieser
Propaganda Blase gelebt und haben
einfach die steilen Thesen Putins als
Wahrheit akzeptiert das ist das eine
finde man sollte sie auch deswegen nicht
verurteilen weil Moldau ist das ärmste
Land Europas ich habe mit Rentnerinnen
Rentnern gesprochen auf Märkten die
Leben von 100 Euro im Monat ich weiß von
Menschen da habe ich in Gesprächen
erfahren die haben im Winter die hatten
sich zu entscheiden
das ist ganz bitter
Durchschnittseinkommen glaube ich
irgendwo um die 500 Euro aber
gleichzeitig hier da sehen wir alle
dieser Frauen die man auf dem Markt so
trifft gleichzeitig aber Preise fast wie
hier bei uns genau in Supermärkte sind
die Preise manchmal
dieselbe und man fragt sich 34 35
Prozent absolut so und ich habe sehr
viel Mitleid für diese Menschen die dann
auf die Straßen gebracht werden weil was
denen gesagt wird okay ihr könnt nach
küchenau so einen Spaziergang machen wie
bezahlen den Bus wir geben euch so was
zum Mittagessen und dann natürlich denkt
man okay das wäre etwas für mich das
damit könnte ich was machen 100 € im
Monat lebst ist die Frage ob du 20 € am
Wochenende vielleicht können wir die
Bilder mal zusehen ich glaube jetzt
gerade gab es wieder große Demonstration
auch nach unserer Abreise dort auch
währenddessen haben wir das gesehen wenn
du 20 Euro nebenbei kannst dann ist das
nicht trivial die Leute und das ist
einfach sehr sehr bitter dass sowas
passiert und dann fragt man sich wie
kann man diese wirtschaftliche prekäre
Situation von diesen Leuten
lösen aber gleichzeitig sehen Sie von
der Regierung nicht so viel
Unterstützung und sehen Sie dass die
Preise noch nach nur nach oben gehen und
sind in so einer Situation wo wo sie
keine andere
Lösung haben also das ist wirklich
bitte ist alles sehr kompliziert
haben meistens mit mit der Sprache zum
Teil auch also das mal zu verstehen das
sehr interessant gesprochen
aber man hat sich ganz lange schwer
damit getan einfach auch nur zu sagen
rumänisch ist die offizielle
Landessprache obwohl es rumänisch ist
man hat es irgendwie anders genannt
gesagt ja da gibt es
andere Begrifflichkeiten dafür mol da
habe ich Staatssprache oder was auch
immer warum warum ist das so wichtig
das Land ist in einem offenen nations
bildungsfindungsprozess es war ja
gespalten historisch hat eine kurze Zeit
lang zu Rumänien gehört eben in der
Zwischenkriegszeit ansonsten war es Teil
der Russlands oder der Sowjetunion und
das das hat natürlich historisch
kulturell das Land die Gesellschaft
geprägt und ähm das sowjetische
Erziehung über über die Jahre
der Menschen das wirkt nach und äh sagen
wir sprechen rumänisch obwohl jeder weiß
dass es rumänisch ist naja es ist ein
eine dialektvariante des rumänisch
kurzzeitig
nach 1990 einige Jahre lang versucht
hier eine eigene Staatssprache zu
etablieren ist aber weitgehend wieder
zurückgekehrt zur Ansicht dass das
tatsächlich rumänisch ist aber es ist
natürlich ein offener offener Nation
finde
es gibt natürlich Unterschiede dazu
Rumänien die eben auf die andere
abweichende Geschichte dieses
Landstrichs zurückgehen ethnisch
sprachlich ist mir natürlich den den
Rumänen nahe aber man hat über die
Sowjetunion übers zahnreich andere
Erfahrungen gemacht und im übrigen auch
in 30 Jahren Transformation dass das
Land ist jetzt 30 Jahre unabhängig von
der Sowjetunion und dieser dieser
Überlegung dass man sich möglicherweise
mit Rumänien wieder vereint das war ja
nur in den Anfangsjahren der im Zuge der
Auflösung der Sowjetunion wirklich ein
Thema und man hat davon Abstand genommen
nicht nur allerdings als kulturellen
politischen Gründen auch aus Gründen
dass das die herrschende Elite dort die
Macht nicht abgeben wollte dass über die
Privatisierung Reichtümer an gehäuft hat
und und den Staat gekatert hat
zurückgenommen wurden
wenn man das Bild von der Geschichte
habe in meiner Kindheit in meiner
sowjetischen Kindheit gab es diese
rumänische Sprache dort nicht er ist
gesprochen das sind komplett erfundene
Sprache die rumänische Sprache wurde
sozusagen umbenannt wurde in dem Sinne
verboten gecancelt und
zum ersten Mal nach diesen Jahrzehnten
Jahrhunderten und hat Molda vor 30
Jahren und die Unabhängigkeit bekommen
das ist eine ehemalige Kolonie und was
passiert dort natürlich die nationale
Gefühle steigen hoch und die Leute die
da raus aus Russland hingebracht worden
die Arbeit in diesem Industrialisierung
wissen Sie die fühlen sich ausgegrenzt
dieses Problem hatte man auch zum Teil
mussten der Ukraine aber das bedeutet
nicht dass diese diese Leute waren
Bürger der Ukraine in dornbas und der
Bürgermeister dass sie irgendwie Russen
sind wie oft dargestellt wurde da sind
keine Russen sie haben tatsächlich
erreichen Integrationsprobleme in der
jeweiligen Ländern auch die russische
Minderheit im Baltikum aber sie sind
keine Russen sie gehören nicht gut sind
ich wollte nur kurz sagen über
moldauische Sprache das war also eine
gezielte Politik wieder die
installiertunion war und das war
rumänisch was mit kyrillischen
Buchstaben geschrieben wurde und man
muss sich vorstellen mehrere Jahren
wurden die Leute erzogen gingen in die
Schule an der Uni und haben diese
Sprache
gelerntischen Schriftzeichen und das ist
so geblieben in transnistrainer also ich
wenn Sie interessieren waren dort heißen
die Cafés la platinte was normale
rumänische Name ist aber wird mit
kyrillischen Buchstaben ähm
das ist
zu transistrieren sprechen was ist das
ist das wie nennen wir das es gibt doch
auch dort einen Zuständigen Oligarchen
ja das ist Spitzname Sheriff
eine sehr bewegte KGB ver Vergangenheit
hat man nennt das auch Sheriff Imperium
diese kontrolliert
ja und
Gutschein ist
er das ist ein ehemaliger KGB-Offizier
und in Sowjet Zeiten war er ziemlich
aktiv auch Ende 80er Jahre um Leute zu
fangen die was mit Rumänien zu tun haben
wollten oder die anbietervereinigung
gedacht haben und so weiter weil seine
ideal war natürlich so wird Union und
dass das so lange wie möglich bleibt
seit also ich glaube er hat angefangen
sein Geschäft zusammen mit seinem Kumpel
in 93 also ein Jahr nach dem Krieg und
das hat mit äh ja
Spirituosen und Zigaretten Business
angefangen aber jetzt ja aber jetzt ihm
gehört alles von Tankstelle bis Cherry
Fußballmannschaft die die einmal Real
Madrid geschlagen hat man hört wenn man
nach transistrien rein fährt man sieht
dieses Stadion und dass die erste
Geschichte die man hört ist wir haben
Real Madrid basiert ja das ist es ist
dort ganz ganz wichtig aber das heißt es
dreht sich alles um diesen einen Mann
und der Herr ruht macht seine Geschäfte
auch mit Deutschland
doch Unternehmungen hier in Deutschland
oder zumindest führen Spuren zu
unternehmen hier in Deutschland ja ich
meine das ist das russische
oligarchensystem in Österreich Skiurlaub
machen sich teure Wohnungen in Berlin
kaufen auf der Champs Elysee einkaufen
gehen und die Kinder auf Privatschulen
in die Schweiz oder nach London London
schicken das ist die Realität und super
Yachten hier in Hamburg reparieren das
sind auch nicht vergessen
selbstverständlich ist es gibt einen ein
Netzwerk von Männern die im Umfeld mit
und durch Putin reich geworden sind und
das beschränkt sich natürlich nicht
alleine nur nur auf Russland selbst
sondern auch auf die Gebiete die aus
putinischer Sicht nach wie vor
eigentlich Tal Russlands sind denn daran
muss man auch immer noch mal erinnern
für Putin ist die größere Tragödie des
20 Jahrhunderts nicht der Holocaust oder
der Zweite Weltkrieg gewesen sondern der
Zerfall der Sowjetunion und er ist
obsessiv darin diese dramatischen
Niederlage zu heilen und deswegen wird
er auch seine Ansprüche auf Moldau oder
auf die Ukraine erst dann aufgeben wenn
er spürt und weiß er kann das nicht
gewinnen und deswegen muss die Ukraine
gewinnen sonst das sehe ich genauso wie
sie dürfte Moldau das nächste Kriegsziel
sein Hunger wird nicht dadurch gestillt
dass wir ihm Zugeständnisse machen